dans la série les mec bizarre dont vos
enfants télécharge les disques après
rust et la fouine nous accueillons
aujourd'hui orelsan
alors vous êtes rappeur et vous êtes
blanc j'ai d'autres points communs et
pierre sarkozy non
je crois qu'il fait les sons je crois
pas qu'ils chantent harry finalement
c'est un petit peu comme christophe
lemaitre en finale du 100 m si vous
demandez ce que vous foutez là quoi un
blanc vieux tous un an ça peut paraître
un peu improbable après on est en 2012
donc l'europe ça évolue ce nom devrait y
en a eu plein akhenaton coup la chaîne
ouais j'avais pas souffert d'un racisme
anti blanc banderas non non non votre
vrai nom là c'est aurélien cotentin vous
êtes né à alençon votre mère est
institutrice mme votre père directeur
d'école vous avez fait des études de
management je continue ou votre carrière
en l'air
mon premier album et ça plaît perdu
d'avancé
je crois que plus on cherche à
crédibilité non la trouve donc j'ai
toujours assumé ça c'est des choses dont
je parle dans les textes grecs je prends
pas ça comme des inconvénients alors au
départ vous écoutiez plutôt nirvana et
c'est vos copains de basket qui nous ont
fait découvrir iam et ntm vous aviez 12
ans et quand vous parlez des gens qui
vous ont influencé vous citez un garçon
que j'ai adoré au moins pour son premier
10 et doc gynéco et vous dites qu'en doc
gynéco décrivait des pigeons picorant du
vomi de toxico ça me parlait plus que
les romances de la chanson française
c'est vrai que quand on a 15 16 ans on
va pas forcément se retrouver dans des
grandes chansons d'amour de garou ou des
choses comme ça et d'entendre des gens
qui faisait des trucs plus concret qui
parlait de réalité qui par les pigeons
de toxico tu vomis rsa me c'est dans ma
rue la chanson alex alors j'ai fait
scandale avec une chanson intitulée sale
[ __ ] sous le nom d' or elle sonne alors
je le dis tout de suite je comprends pas
pourquoi y ait eu ce scandale voilà
c'est quand une mauvaise vous quitte la
première des choses il dit sale [ __ ]
quand je vais revenir
franchement je comprends pas pourquoi
tout le monde m'a pris la tête avec ça
mais au-delà de ça même quand un gars
qui est oui sa copine s'il y avait un
équivalent de sale [ __ ] pour les galas
et le direct alors donc à l'époque tout
le monde lui est tombé dessus j'étais
devenu de charles manson quoi c'était un
c'était marrant enfin c'était marrant
c'était intéressant pour moi ils ont
fait chiffres avaient été annulés des
francofolies du bourges sentant de
bourges daniel colling avait gardé le
concert mais il y avait des manifs les
mic et vous étiez dans la lessiveuse
comme on dit ouais alors ne vais pas
baisser les bras vous sortez votre
deuxième album le chant des sirènes avec
un titre qui s'appelle suicide social
aussi très très pro vo c'est un mec qui
va se suicider cette chanson c'est une
façon de parler un peu des du
communautarisme et le fait de voir la
société sous forme de couches sociales
c'est un cliché c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde va être
gayfriendly etc vous dites pour prouver
que t'es pas homophobe pourra bientôt
que tu suces des types faisait pas peur
de mettre les oignons à dos coup sinon
non c'est ce que dit le personnage dans
la chanson après c'est vrai que il ya
souvent des communautés qui sont plus
facilement aux français que d'autres
c'est rarement je parle aussi des
ouvriers de danger pas dans le collectif
d'ouvriers qui est qu'ils sont en train
de dire oui mais c'est contre le
prolétariat
non c'est très bien ce que vous faites
et puis alors il ya une chanson qui
s'appelle raelsan donc vous revenez sur
la polémique évidemment sale [ __ ] et
vous dites je voulais tout plaquer
quitté le son j'ai presque abandonné
sans faire ma deuxième livraison et dans
le chant des sirènes nous dit une
chanson les requins avec qui jeta fait
les suceurs qui me gratte et m'ont
poussé à cracher un deuxième disque
ratez pas jury n est pas du tout raté
votre deuxième livre merci maman merci
et vous serez au bataclan le 14 décembre
le lendemain le joey starr qui est de 13
200 essais complets et on refait une
date au mois de février ayant bravo
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent vos parents de
cet enseignant de ce que vous faites en
ce moment comment ils ont vous vécu le
le buzz avec sale [ __ ] maman oui michel
drucker a dit sale [ __ ] tu vois maman
faut pas m'en vouloir quand je le dis
moi mais je fais comme michel drucker
on en a discuté je leur ai expliqué ils
ont ils ont bien compris pourquoi
j'avais fait ça notamment je me rappelle
une phrase de de ma grand mère parce que
mon grand père a eu un peu plus de mal à
comprendre pourquoi j'ai fait ça parce
que c'est une autre génération
comprennent pas comment on peut faire un
truc un peu provocant avec des gros mots
et c est ma grand-mère lui disais mais
moi quand on se dispute j'ai envie de
t'étrangler j'aurais pu la faire à la
chance
vous l'avez bien suis pas fan
fan j'avais été choquée c'est vrai en
même temps très gêné dans la polémique
parce que je comprends bien quand un
artiste fin l'art ne doit pas connaître
de limites voilà en même temps quand il
ya des textes qui peuvent pour certains
poussent et aussi à la violence mais
c'est tellement dur il ya tellement de
femmes qui se font tabasser qui meurent
tous les jours je vois tellement ça au
quotidien que je ne peux pas le retirer
de ma façon de d'entendre vos textes
idem sur les homos quoi donc je sais
qu'il ya un vrai débat sur cents
surpassant sur c'est quoi l'art jusqu'où
ça va et qui décide que c'est de l'art
ou que c'est plus de l'art mais en même
temps je ne peux pas retirer tout ce que
je vois de la vie réelle quand j'écoute
vos textes après ça a pas de rapport
pour moi dans ces cas là on peut plus
faire de chansons qui parlent de cancer
on peut plus faire de chansons qui
parlent de deux meurtres de crime pour
moi c'est il faut savoir dire quand je
regarde un film je rapporte pas tout à
moi non plus les gens sont beaucoup
moins con qu'on le croit c'est à dire
que les gens savent analyser une
question de conneries c'est une question
de sensibilité je comprends qu'on puisse
ne pas aimer après censure et ça reste
une autre histoire bien dans orelsan
pensez michel drucker dans vivement
dimanche
dimanche prochain
est ce que c'est un spécial rappeur
thiat tu devrais faire cesser de remuer
bien sur les courts est sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu